each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so we're very very happy to have
bill Freeman here from next door he is
one of the top people in vision and he
is also the thesis advisor of one of our
new post Docs so so he's going to be
talking to us about where computer
vision needs help from computer science
and machine learning as opposed to
computer science well I yeah that's
thanks a lot it's a real pleasure to be
here I've heard about this lab and it's
very nice to join and engage with you
all and also I'm glad take part in this
communal experience which I'm told is
what the lecture is like so that's
that's fine yes so here's I want to talk
about just little bit about my
background so you can get used to
hearing my voice and then computer
vision applications and then techniques
and problems that uh that we need to
help on so first about me I been around
for a long time I guess so I worked
originally for six years at this company
that's now bankrupt and gone Polaroid as
an electrical engineer working on
electronic cameras and printers so there
is an apple to that we programmed on and
made a so called video printer that
would do this amazing thing they would
give you color prints from your computer
sorry what your um 81 286 yeah yet some
pads on yeah
so the printer was oh he was a black and
white monitor that exposed color film
through through three different color
filter wheels and we thought that was
the coolest thing okay so then I my wife
and I wanted to have an experience
living in a foreign culture before we
start having kids so we lived in China
for a year and I was a foreign expert
it's we threw no intention of our own we
picked really the world's most polluted
city I mean I think it is the most loose
in the world ty un chonchi China and and
so there's us driving on the family
transportation around campus sorry but
they serve really good chinese food and
then typically so I lost I 20 or 30
pounds and i typically men lost weight
in women gain weight I don't know why
but sorry yeah so when I was in China I
read this book vision by david marr and
I got really excited about computer
vision and vision and it's going to be
reissued this year by MIT press so if
you want to also get inspired by it i
really recommend it even though it's you
know 20 or 30 years old it's just a
beautiful book so i applied to MIT for
grad school and came there and then
after four years i worked at get this a
fundamental research lab that it was
across the street from MIT for nine
years and that's it it's still there
it's no it's still it's still going
strong and I was the only vision person
there when I was hired so I feel real
sense of camaraderie with chuck was in a
very similar situation
but here's what happened a lot more
vision people came and then we got a big
vision group after that anyway so here's
me so it was a really wonderful lab it's
not quite as fun demel now fundamental
now as it used to be but we could do
what we wanted to do and then actually
this is a picture of my one more my more
applied projects it's a television set
that you can control with hand signals
so there's the user there and you hold
up your hand and tv turns on and has
some on-screen controls and then you
move your hand and the computer would
track your hand and let you use it like
a buttonless mouse and you could adjust
the controls that way right all vision
yeah and then in 2001 I moved to MIT
I've been faculty there since so I have
a sample of to everyone I've talked with
it this lab tells me they're they're
free to do what they want to do and also
I know that each of those my sample of
two are really smart people so that Wow
so there's a whole audience full of
really smart people who we do whatever
they want to do why don't I get them
interested in my problems so so that's
the goal of this talk actually I'm
actually so the audience are two people
one is anyone who might want to dabble
in vision this talk is for you and then
the other for people who don't think
they'll babble and vision but want to
just learn what's going on in vision
this talk is also for you incentive
compatible oh I see yeah cuz I'm not
that smart I don't know okay so so the
way I want a structure then is kind of
start out by just talking about existing
computer vision applications what's out
there now and then talk about sort of
where we're stuck or and this is a kind
of a mix of where we're stuck in
interesting problems to me so things and
low-level vision things in high low
vision and then this
lanius problems okay so here's just as a
way to start here's a list of companies
that are involved in computer vision
let's start with the first one cognacs
cognis has come an old style computer
vision company they do computer vision
for manufacturing so there you're going
to have controlled lighting it's going
to be like a factory you can control
everything really and you have the task
of doing computer vision so it's almost
a different animal as far as the
problems go because you don't have all
these issues of lighting variations size
variations occlusion all the
uncertainties you have in sort of real
world vision but they're a successful
company they're in needham I guess yeah
and they've been around for a long time
there was you know what computer didn't
do well I can save lives so here's a
company that installs cameras in
swimming pools and looks for people who
drowned or who are about to drown who
have not yet drowned so I've been
successful so I need people who have not
yet drowned and they haven't installed
in all sorts of places in the US and
Europe and you know here's from the
London Times saved by a computer
lifeguard you know someone's at the
bottom and and the lifeguard for some
reason is such a crowded pool they
actually couldn't see the person at the
bottom but the camera system could see
them and alerted the lifeguards so so
this is you know this is a great
application for a computer vision it's
what makes it easy I guess is the fact
they've got stationary camera and the
pool doesn't change lighting variations
are going to happen a lot and and so you
have to learn to recognize someone still
on the bottom but they can do that
that might yeah I so I I don't really
know the limits of this thing but I
would assume that if you don't sell for
a while held your breath that something
would go off Yeah Yeah right yes so
here's another application which is
always about to happen but I really do
believe it's about to happen this is an
Israeli company founded by I'm non
Joshua who's a former MIT graduate
student who is without a doubt the
richest computer vision researcher in
the world I think he's like worth half a
billion or something based on this
company and they are going to save a lot
of lives to initially though they'll
just help people drive so it's a single
camera system it is installed behind the
rear view mirror and looks ahead it
gives you another things you can do we
can give you Lane warnings if you drift
across the lane it can adjust your
brights to account for an oncoming car
and you know over time these things are
going to take more and more control over
your driving and actually is just going
to be a whole lot of warnings right so
that's thing every time I talk with them
they're oh yeah they're gonna be
installed in the land a year
mercedes-benz happen yeah so they got
you have billion yeah they had done
great which company was who bought like
a third them know they well quite
actually a third or a half of them
anyway he's doing well and also you know
this company's doing well so they that's
actually really exciting i thought that
how could they possibly compete with you
know GM and Chrysler and stuff and but
actually there are you know there are
they've got 25 people working for years
on this one problem and they're going to
nail it you know they've got a real-time
system that does this better than any of
the company's labs do it okay
no I do want to play ok ok but so
they're doing it right yes yeah well
yeah well so I mean I guess the answer
is I don't know all the trade-offs
involved I know one thing is that the
industry is extremely cost conscious and
the big thing that helped this company
start was the fact that instead of using
two cameras they were going to use one
camera and that was their big advantage
because they have to have two cameras
and there's enough to have these
calibrated cameras and if you could do
it all of one camera then everything's
so much cheaper and simpler so you know
they're sensitive to that kind of a
price difference two cows vs 1 and so I
don't know the direct answers your
question of what about other particular
ways of doing it but I mean this this
has the advantage of just being able to
do it one car at a time let's see ok
then it Merle the lab in Cambridge i
worked on computer vision for computer
games and these have actually not the
ones that i worked on but others have
come to market so this is from the sony
i tuoi and of course microsoft will have
its own version coming out it not
directly based on I mean not only based
on vision based on vision plus depths
also is my understanding there's a lot
of interest in computer vision for
identity recognition
oh really okay and and then there's
actually I dare say this word here
there's this google which of course uses
vision for to help you with finding the
images that you want and there's
Microsoft which has a wonderful
photosynth system which from talking
with my friends in the research they
have all these ways in mind that you can
start making money and then just these
are not current camera companies but
they're just things that obviously have
to happen Shirley household raava robots
will have vision in the future and
surely that's going to happen and be a
big application and then another one is
surely vision will be used to analyze
YouTube content to optimize ad placement
and I had no number of companies that
are working on that particular problem
now and surely that will happen too so
these are other future applications for
computer vision okay so that's kind of a
little survey of where it might be
useful where it is useful and then now I
want to talk about specific technology
and I gotta say this is this is not a
talk about a particular research project
to talk about a research field so the
way this is structured is to kind of
give high level things about particular
things I've worked on or I'm familiar
with so feel free to ask questions if
you want to go deeper okay so you can
kind of divide the vision world into low
level vision and high-level vision hi
low vision is recognizing objects low
low vision is like sort of image in a
field of numbers out so you might want
to know what does this image to look
like if it were made sharper what does
this image look like if it's wordee
blurred other things like that whereas
high level is kind of image in string of
characters out I love interpretation
single image
let's see in what I'm going to be
talking about it's almost always a
single image but that's certainly not
the field that's just kind of my bias
you know stereo is important part videos
important part I would call lo level and
sometimes you need to do low level in
order to do high-level successfully yeah
well because fitting this to taxonomy if
the the output is a field of numbers
then then I'm calling it low level but
you might need to have high level
interpretation of the image in order to
do it right I suppose yeah yeah okay so
all right let's start with fundamentals
all right how do you take a picture well
in the old days you got lens got film
behind it and took photo nowadays the
the image is just a set of data is not
the final output and this opens up a
whole new sort of technological area
it's called computational photography so
it's no longer film lens to film and
then here's the image it's really lends
to or lens collection to censor and then
then you have to interpret your sensor
sensor data so there's been an explosion
of cameras because of this degree of
freedom now it's we can we don't have to
stop at the image anymore so you have
trinocular binocular cameras you have
coded aperture cameras which I'll talk
about a little more in detail multi lens
cameras that give you a picture of all
every light ray coming in every
direction and this one is very cute time
to explain too much in detail but it's
called wavefront coding you make a
blurry image but you can decode it and
make everything be sharp so it's a real
it was a real nice advance about from
about 10 or 15 years ago
no it's a it's blurred in a particular
way so that all depths images that all
different depths are blurred in the same
way so if you just looked at the photo
that you made with this crazy lens it
would be blurry but it has the benefit
that if you then process it with a
computer you can make every depth be in
focus you can have serve an infinite
depth of field actually this one you can
only make all the depths in focus
there's with this one you can make any
particular depth in focus but but the
idea is the same that you're going to
make some image that you then have to
post process by computer to pull out
some feature that you want from the
world
right it's not secure exactly and
actually to talk about trying to that in
a bit also so we just want to sort of
frame this problem in a mathematical way
so what is the camera sensor element
record well here's a scene and I always
try to put pictures of my children in
the talks so these are my three kids
they're on the fence light comes out in
all directions here and goes through the
camera off six in some crazy way and
lands at say a particular sensor element
so first of all here's a pop quiz for
you all what is the dimensionality of
the set of all Ray's coming out in the
world is it a two-dimensional thing a
three-dimensional thing for dementia
laughs I dimensional well well so here's
how I think of it from every position
you've got you've got a 2d sweep of
possible positions that the rate can be
coming from and then in any given
position it's got two degrees of freedom
it can go in so the set of the so-called
light filled the set of all possible
rays and in May emanating in this room
is a four-dimensional thing two degrees
of freedom so you got this yeah two
dimensions yeah so okay so
mathematically then the light field is
this 40 thing that we're going to
rasterize as a single vector and then
what is the sensor see well see some
projection some positive linear
combination of the elements of this
vector and then a little bit noise and
that's what one pixel sees and then
here's a camera a camera is a some
matrix T that does some linear
combination different potentially at
each different pixel of all the light
rays coming in the world and then what
is photography photography is solving
this equation okay here's your sensor
data why and you want to given T and
your knowing about your camera and
having your your sensor data you want to
figure out what X was which is this
edible
you could phrase it that way you might
have some estimate of the variance yeah
i mean this matrix too well this matrix
t could could describe a stereo camera
yeah well it'll work so you could have
this the set of all light rays in this
room is this 40 vector and camera a over
here takes one linear projection of it
gives you that top part of your
observation matrix and then the bottom
part of your observation vector is
formed by taking some other linear
combination of the well that there you
go this is really under determined I
maybe that's what you're getting at I
mean so this is a little in general 2d
projection and this is like this 40
animal how can you possibly estimate it
well there you go this is the the main
point of Part A of the talk you need
good statistical priors on images in on
light fields because otherwise you can't
possibly estimate it linear wait you
mean this engineer t well I guess
because I'm sweeping although
nonlinearities under the rug I'm
assuming you can sort of back them out I
mean CCD sensors are pretty well linear
and then if you have a regular camera it
goes through this distorting
non-linearity in order to pre distort it
in anticipation of being shown on a
monitor but in general you can often in
so-called camera RAW format get out
something that's pretty close to a
linear function of the light
which is sort of the anger and my my
legs
right so all that stuff is encompassed
in this matrix T which so that this
thing x is is a each little element in X
is one ray at some particular angle and
then this matrix T tells you how much of
that light is going to land on any given
sensor element so that the non-linearity
of this thing bending over to there is
all described in the positions of this
ok color so then you have a different
matrix yeah right so so that you can
also talk about that new matrix T so you
can break up why into maybe the red
parts are up here the green parts are
there and the blue parts are there and
then this matrix T is going to be
different for each one of those colors
you can you could describe it that way
yeah so you one cameras going to one T
and other cameras get another tea and
and as a camera designer you're free to
make up any physically realizable T that
you want so let's look at an example
yeah yeah so and so so this is what's
nice about it turns photography into an
inference problem you know solving that
little matrix equation so let's look at
one particular example of the all this
let's talk about lenses and D focus so
now we're coming back in the
conventional ordinary lens and here's
the focal plane here's the camera sensor
if we move back from the so this is a
conventional lens we move back from this
plane of focus it focuses focus is there
and then at the center you get a blurred
image and if you're blooming back move
back more you get a more blurred image
so you have a depth dependent point
spread function and you can sort of use
I mean when you took a look at a
conventional photo and you see really
blurry thing you say well it's probably
in the background in the early Shadwell
has made in the foreground so you can a
little bit use it to estimate depth but
their number of reasons why it's
difficult you can make it a whole lot
easier for yourself if you say I'm not
going to use a conventional aperture I'm
going to use this aperture okay that's
my camera aperture now you've got the
specially designed code and now when you
move change depth so here's actually a
picture of a the image at the sensor of
a point of light at different depths and
here's what sort of schematic of how it
looks now you have this again sort of
scaling according to depth of the object
but you've now sort of introduced this
this modulation into the point spread
function and you've designed it in a
clever way so that it's easier to
discriminate different depths so what's
going to happen this is the so-called
point spread function how that relates
to the image you see is the the images
in the world gets involved everyone with
me sterilized a liquor involved okay it
gets convolve by this point red function
so you want to design this thing so if
you take an image convolve it with that
you can now easily distinguish what
parts of the resulting image are are
blurred by what size of this thing so so
now you the resulting image is the kind
of a folding together of the actual
image plus this funky little point
spread function that you've designed and
you want to design it in a way well so
each different depth right right only
one it went so it's especially its own
its scales with the depth of the object
so you've got the scene there each
different depth is going to give you a
different size of this point red
function and it convulsed with the image
so now you get another image and you
have to decide so is that what it really
looked like and it's just a sharp
picture of it or is that thing blurred
by this funky thing at some depth so you
have to make that decision and so if you
have a conventional aperture there's
going to be different scalings of this
sort of pill box function and if you
have this coded aperture it's going to
be different scalings of this funky
thing that we designed to be very
easily discriminant in the if you come
from if you're an electrical engineering
crowd this has nice zeros in the Fourier
transform and as the thing scales you
can identify what the scaling is by what
frequencies in the resulting involved
image are zeroed out and so that you can
design this thing to make it easy to
discriminate what depth has been blurred
by yeah that's part of ice useful it's
like the odds that you come across this
thing in the world are yeah yeah and
then here's a little kind of just a
visually intuitive thing to explain this
these so all of these images have been
yes I guess Deacon so they've all been
blurred by this size of either this one
or this one and then you try to under
them by the wrong sizes or the correct
size if you have this conventional
aperture you can then this image
convolve with this explains what you see
or this image convolve with this
explains what you see either one
explains the data pretty well so you can
either say it was blurred by a big
blurring thing and it's kind of sharpish
where was blurred bites a little tiny
blur and the thing itself out there was
really quite blurred so you have this
sort of meta mirtha some two different
ways of explaining your data whereas
with this engineered aperture it's much
clearer that this is the only solution
that explains things so yeah so it's
like a it's like a two-for-one you get
out both a full resolution image and an
estimate of what the depth is who is you
can deep involve it so so here's an
application digital refocusing from a
single image yeah is that like just for
these slides that possible I mean the
the video projectionists will come in
and kill me but but just for these
slides okay so let's see so here's an
all focus image we've recovered we've
estimated what the depth is
and you and not and because you now that
you know the depth you can go back and
say well I'm just going to you know I
took the photo but what I really wanted
to do I really wanted to focus on her
and have the other people people re so
now that you know the depth of you where
you can just you can generate that image
so this is refocusing after the exposure
and then now actually oh no I didn't
want to get her I really want to get him
but again you just from that same
picture that you took that has served
the image and the depth information all
folded together in one data set you can
you can d convolve and and get this guy
sharp and the other two blurred or you
can do the last one to him blur together
right in this case that's great what was
the project so it was a yea high
kurtosis that the gradients had a
particular distribution that they they
really wanted to be zero in other words
every pixel really like to be the same
value as his neighbor but occasionally
you could vary and it could vary in a
particular way and that's actually
though that's that story is the whole
point of this first low-level vision
part sorry no no this is they're not my
kids they're yes their students so
that's sort of kid yes so okay so here's
my first so what I have in whatever
fraction of my talk I'm going to get
through here's a common format for some
of these what the problem is
applications of it and references in
case you want to like pursue it further
so here are the problem is how do we
design this camera transfer matrix to
optimally optimally record image
information and also allow optimal
reconstruction of depth there's actually
there's trade-off in designing that
little code you can make it really easy
to discriminate depths but then you lose
something is harder to actually find out
what the data was at those depths
because you have to throw in these zeros
and the Fourier transform and then
you've lost that information so this is
tension between identifying what the
depth is and recording all the image
information at all the depths so that's
a problem we don't know how to solve if
you're interested you know yeah
yeah yeah I'm like us yes if it works I
mean you know the noise level is pretty
low and it's the signal-to-noise ratios
are really pretty high so as long as you
don't do something that's really
unstable it will probably work to your
noise you mean different priors well
that size of the we have just kind of
i'm going to show you an example in a
sec there's only one really good prior
that people have and that's a real short
coming in the field and what we really
need are better priors tease got all
these other constraints on it you've got
to decide what you can actually build
and so that's yeah Rex Yeah Yeah right
yeah so that's its it yeah why is that a
painful subject for me um so we've
looked into compressive sensing and we
kind of think it's not all that useful
for images but it does have a yeah it's
a related problem
what's your next slide Oh answer your
question yeah well we'll talk more about
price so okay so that's exactly this is
the main point of this low level part
the real short coming in vision and
image processing is that we don't have
we're just a long way from having a
great prior on images and it's a real
interesting field but we're just not
there so so if you if you had a
wonderful prior on images in other words
you could draw from your prior to get
something look like an image you can
take a noisy image and combine it with
your prior and get a great-looking image
out that would just be so useful every
every low-level problem you can imagine
needs a strong priorities here's another
example another problem noise removal
there's original yeah a ton of noise now
you've got this in the serb ever knows
bayes rule I assume anyway you've got
this tension between the so-called
likelihood term and the prior term and
then you've got this lambda that you
dial which one you favor most if you say
the likelihood term if you really really
trust your data then you say okay that's
my estimate the image you know there it
is I trust the data but if you say aha
that's such an unlikely looking image i
think i'm going to i think they're so
loud noise added to it i'm going to
estimate what the underlying image was
and estimate the noise and so there's
this knob where you just how much you
trust your image how much you trust your
prior and there's like here's one
compromise between the two and it just
doesn't look like very image like at all
if we had a great image prior when you
cranked up the thing saying i really
trust my prior ninjas you'd get
something that looked like a good image
but nobody gets things that look like
good images now if they really crank up
their prior they get stuff like this so
there's a place where we really need
good priors on images and what is a good
prior an image something that you looked
at say ok there's a good image and if
you crank up your prior knob you would
get something look like an image it
wouldn't be the right image but it would
be something to look like an image and
so
it could be that I I held out hope that
that you can go pretty far even without
high level stuff but well for example
nonparametric prior if you went and had
a billion patches of real images and you
went and found the closest one teach one
of these I think you'd do a really good
job at removing noise Yeah Yeah right
well no I mean I think it's a very
similar problem and I at the end and I
think people made a lot of progress with
doing that yeah yeah these are done sir
parametric priors okay here's another
problem that requires good priors that's
removing blur from cameras so so here's
a picture that tells the whole story
this one's got the the subject and the
photographer in the same picture she
took a picture of herself in the mirror
move the camera during exposure and
that's the output and I just and so
here's the role our algorithm which uses
this prior that i'll explain in just a
sec which tries to look at this and say
okay even though i've got only a low
level understanding of the world i'm
gonna try to guess what the image was
and here's the best guess and here's a
close-up of it oops original and this is
just to show you that it's a hard
problem here's just boosting high
frequencies certainly naive sharpening
and then here's yeah yeah yes
yeah well that's what you should do and
what we do what you should do is what
Kodak does sometimes and they get a lot
of people in the room and say okay here
here's image am HP wishing you're like
better okay here's a JPG wishing like
better you know and so forth supervised
learning yeah yeah yeah or just have
people tell you what looks best there's
it's a whole yeah well taking the true
taking an unblurred picture and
comparing it is a good thing but the I
mean in some sense that's you think
that's the gold standard it turns out
however that like looking at the sum of
squared difference between pixel values
as nada is not always a good indicator
of how different it seems perceptually
to you and so that's actually another
little sub feel this nobody's really
soft well and how do you get a nice
mathematical measure of the visual
dissimilarity between two pictures and
that's a field of open research yeah I
mean to doing the obvious thing of
taking the sum of squared differences
between the two pixel values is subject
to some really for example the trivial
thing if you had like a one intensity
level difference between them but you
lined it up so in vertical streaks you
could see that right away whereas if you
randomized it you couldn't see at all
and that's just a one of many different
things that messes up the so called
squared error criterion and i should say
just right now with it yeah you think
I'm this um so I gotta tell you right
now that the person i think is really
the best for almost every low level
vision thing is my former MIT office
mate arrow Simon Kelly so he's a
professor at NYU now and he makes a he's
just great he does he's come up with
this what I think is the best so far
perceptually a perceptual error metric
between two inches and anyway so his
webpage would if you google eat
ero which is his first name you can get
him at least on the first or second
listing and anyway he's really good at
these sort of metrics so okay here's
that let me just kind of frame this
problem here's your data blurry image
and here's what you want to find you
want to find this explanation for it of
a sharp image convolved with some
unknown so-called blur colonel okay I
just want to explain what this is this
is a picture of what you would see if
you photographed a little speck of light
and moves the camera in the same way
that you did when you photograph made
this picture it's the so-called impulse
response it's what a point of light
would give you and then if the thing is
that every point of light gives you that
so therefore that instructs you to
convulse thing with that latent image
and you get the your data so that's your
model for your data and what I love
about this problem is just beautifully
underdetermined so here's your data well
how can you explain the data here's one
perfectly good way of explaining the
data that's what was out there and you
took a sharp picture of it you know
particularly from this low-level point
of view you have you know why why isn't
it it is that is that something wrong
with that pile of numbers in some way
well that's where your prior on images
comes in here's another perfectly good
explanation of it that was was out there
and you moved your cameras such that the
point spread function look like this and
that would also give you that data okay
and then finally here's another one
could be that was there and you move the
cam like this and you give that all
these perfectly explains it data how do
you pick between them well you've got to
have a prior on images and you can have
kind of a high-low prior to low low five
highly will probably have to go and say
okay this is buildings i know the
building edge is supposed to be sharp so
i can't be right but that's just going
to be hard to do you can't i surley this
page i don't think you can do a high
level interpretation of every image what
you really want is a nice low level
signal level prior that will let you
look at these things to say I think this
is the right one you know yes you can
also do that so i should say in this
work that we're doing we have a serve
pathetic
week prior and blur kernels justice got
to be all positive it's gotta be sparse
but what you could have a stronger one
saying that there's got to be some kind
of low acceleration trajectory of the
camera that explains the whole thing no
not now um so okay so but you you all
are great at this here just just try
this out sharper blurred blurred you've
never seen this picture before but you
can figure out there's blurred this one
ah what do you think no I think sharp
yeah and that one blurred yep okay so
you're very good at it here is our prior
which sort of does okay it's sort of
mean and I mean on the one hand this is
what we've done on the other hand it's
it's really a long way from what you
need to do a number of people have
pointed out that if you look at the
statistics of a gradient operator or
really any bandpass filter operator on
images it looks very different than it
would look like on random noise its
so-called heavy-tailed Kurt otic so
here's the value of the gradient this is
just the difference between consecutive
pixels and here's a hit the histogram
the log pre-conceived occurrence of how
often those difference values occurs so
most of time an image pixel is the same
as neighbor and then everyone smile it
changes yeah
yeah it's the operator point five minus
point five convolve with the image
that's that's so that's what i mean by
this yeah a little bit boat yeah right
execute you've got it so so and if you
take a blurred image it's going to have
a different histogram and so this yeah
there's a little yeah I mean it does
depend someone on the image so what we
did for this work was we fit a function
so this curve actually for this image I
this is our model for all images the
same is right here and we fit a little
parametric model to that histogram and
said that's what we think the that's our
prior model on the gradients of images
and now that's week in so many ways but
it kind of works what does it mean to do
me too yeah yeah yeah I mean actually
your colleagues at Microsoft it Redmond
my summer intern just came back and told
me what he did and actually that was
that was his summer project to go come
up with different I think I did came up
with a two primary model for this thing
and come up with different parameter
settings based on different parts of the
image so you can do better than what
we're doing but this is what we did and
so we then here's our here's the problem
now we've got the reconstruction
constraint that whatever you come up
estimate for the image and whatever you
ask me for the lures got to convulse
what you saw we've got this prior on the
image gradient so it's going to help you
identify what this should be and we've
got this week prior on the blur colonel
and
and then we did the sort of Bayesian
estimation try to solve this there's
some details it turns out you don't want
to actually try to estimate both the
blur and the latent image at the same
time what you really want to do is
estimate the blur kernel and marginalize
over all possible latent images and then
fix that and estimate the image but
that's another talk and so is this base
rule this is your likelihood term and
here's our little prior saying that we
want the gradient values to have a
certain distribution and then our prior
on that yeah yeah yeah and if we could
just do the last one more time please I
know who made it happened Wow incredible
okay so so here's the output of it the
original photograph inside a museum now
I take / and here's our estimate of
lower kernel and our estimate of the
image now there's all sorts of problems
if you could speak up and this is where
we need help anyway this you know it's
still kind of noisy but it does a good
job in general yeah well that was I
think yeah i'm yeah well no I I think we
could have done a better job of mashing
the college I think it's just a kind of
a global 3 by 3 matrix we could have
estimated the end I don't know why it's
not good better than it is here's the
amount of Z come blind nothing against
matlab but it's a hard problem and it
doesn't do very well so here is a
close-up of the original the sort of
Brand X reconstruction in our
reconstruction which you know properly
it's using a Richardson Lucy
deconvolution and doing an iterative way
to estimate both the image and the blur
at the same time it's a is they don't
have an explicit prior on their image in
that
okay okay all right so it's a dip it's a
kind of a more Gaussian like prior and
just to just one more thing about priors
and images so another way look at this
problem is if someone gave you a stack
of a billion patches what's a good way
to model it and and this is what people
have come up with so far this is um a
this is an analysis based on looking at
las lots of images if you take a sparse
linear combination of these you can
model these little 16 by 16 image
patches very well and this was a kind of
a breakthrough paper in the year 2000
what's cute about this is it looks very
similar to receptive field responses in
monkeys and cats and things so there's
some sense that mammals in the early
stages of visual processing are pulling
out these little kind of fundamental
level atoms of the visual world and we
can find them too if we process our
caches properly but this is only the
first step yeah yeah for images for all
patches if you take a sparse and that's
the thing it's not just a linear comment
you can do PCA and get that this is a
sparse linear combination take a sparse
linear combination of these you can
reconstruct all their training image
patches in some optimal way optimizing
the particular function they had
yeah yeah yeah yeah so this is one good
sparse basis but then there's kind of
more there's the nonlinear stage which
is kind of yet to be determined on top
of that so these are reasonable set of
atoms you might try to build up image
patches with but but it's it's we've got
to go beyond just looking at those I
mean so so this is about ten years ago
and I haven't really seen people go
beyond it in a nice way and so this is
I'm just pointing out this problem
number two statistical characterization
images use fall over the place here's my
officemate there so here's some
references that you might look at this
is a deep blowing paper that I showed
you the results of and we've done some
other work on it as of other people so I
want to get to other parse I'm going to
skip this marker bana fields it just in
general people who are Marco random
field mavens we need to order handle
higher order click potentials higher
dimensional state variables do inference
on them better that would be helpful to
us so it one last I know I just trying
to time this thing I'm still about not
quite halfway through the slides so with
the things I talked about before we're
kind of parametric style low-level
priors I just want to show you what is I
think the future or what is just a
wonderful present anyway and these are
sort of nonparametric priors for images
so there was this real breakthrough
paper by a berkeley graduate student
about 10 years ago that just did you
know all these people didn't work on
texture synthesis and he came along and
came up with the simplest possible
texture synthesis algorithm algorithm
which gave results which are so much
better than anybody else's results and
it's just the most brain-dead algorithm
let me tell you what it is suppose
you're you've got the you got this patch
of here make me more stuff like this and
you're going to go on make so I like
there's your patch of reference stuff
make me more stuff like this here's what
you've built so far you want to try to
figure out what value should I put in
that pixel well you just go look at the
neighborhood around it go find where
you've seen that before see what was
there in those pixels and take a random
sample
from them and put that there and you go
and do that and you just get fantastic
image synthesis results you can also do
with patches instead of single pixels
synthesize a patch and so here examples
here's the input stuff a little small
one is the input and then the big one is
the output and you can just do you know
great texture synthesis so you'll notice
this is not the same image is that any
any one little place you know it's a
another version of it and you can do
goopy stuff you can do regular stuff
it's it's just a just a wonderful
brain-dead way of making great texture
so here is a sorry right so um so yo
yeah yeah so you know it kind of does
what you would expect after you think
about it so if you depends how big your
patches you're grabbing pieces of if
you've got a really big pasture grabbing
peaches of pieces of one that covers the
whole face then you're going to come up
with a face because you've got that
you're sort of unfortunate radio but if
it's really small then you're just going
to come up with little contours that are
some horrible distorted you know
creature yeah yeah yeah sure yeah right
so there's a bug right there yeah yes
yeah it couldn't end in here so actually
this is um it's a little bit symptomatic
of the algorithm used to make this it's
it's done in a raster scan way in this
particular thing so you you sit there
and you try to match them here's the
picture of it you're you trying to come
up with this patch so you say well I
want this borders to match this patch
but I want this border to match this
patch there and these are unconstrained
so you you might imagine you could sort
of paint yourself into a corner at in
the bottom right and actually that is
kind of what happens on that picture
that is a little more artifact de down
here than it is up there we have more
freedom to two things
I see from their zone sorry this is on a
timer there's only one here but there's
lots of them there yeah this is this is
the one that has you see the all the way
around and this one yeah yeah yeah yeah
so so this is another I don't know if
another good kind of computer science ii
problem how do you construct and manage
a nice nonparametric is no signal prior
so i select exempli so this is these
things are kind of weak and that they
only reproduce one different particular
texture stuff you'd really like to have
a nonparametric prior that just could do
the whole world and that's going to take
a lot more patches and so you want to
manage these patches you want to pick
the right ones you want to be able to
find them quickly and so one thing
that's going to come up again again in
the remainder of this talk is a good
nearest neighbor search and high
dimensions now that's supposed to been
solve somehow but you know still a
problem so really good nearest neighbor
search and high dimension would be
really useful on computer vision so now
let's go to high level things if that's
okay so this is low level and mainly
it's an underdetermined problem and
really the big thing is finding a nice
prior images in high low vision i think
of it as mostly a comment oriole
complexity problem so suppose you want
to recognize chairs well here are some
chairs okay go generalize from those and
you know you know if you go yeah this is
a hard one but so I mean it's just is an
extreme case of with in class
variability each one of these is a chair
it's hard to come up with kind of image
based model for what that chair is so
just to kind of so this is the high
level problem of image in and then Nino
words out describing it for example so
there are number of issues you can
approach a problem with a generative or
discriminative models so a generative
model might have
parts and there's a relationship between
them and and you can draw from this and
yeah you get a little bit of penalty
gets there yeah yeah it's describing the
penalty for violating yeah yeah and then
this graphic is trying to say well you
have a lot of data points these are
faces these are not faces learn a
classifier and and then you can decide
something to face by just seeing within
an image enough of the little face piece
is to say AHA there's a face there or
you can require that they be in certain
configuration these are really the
issues that are going to kill you you've
got to be invariant to view point to
illumination condition to occlusion to
scale the deformations the clutter these
are what make the problem hard and
you've got to choose whether to look a
little crazy crazy features will look at
pixels I'll talk about that in a bit so
I serve promised in the abstract a
little histories and it's not the
biggest Regis here just going to show
you what's what's happened in the past
we go back in time this is what people
look like back in time so you know a
little geometrical things that's what
computer vision researchers very
reasonably simplified the problem is
they we're not going to solve all
problems we're just going to say that
things are geometrical and that's what
we're looking for and so so we're going
to try to find things like these so
here's the model we're looking for here
the input image and a high we found them
you know and that's that's the problem
and and then it really becomes a kind of
computer science problem where you have
a interpretation tree you see how far
down the tree you have searched so this
is some people are researchers at MIT at
the time I think analyze this and ok
here's a real world image but now you've
pre-processed it to pre-process it to
just look at edges and now you've got to
go look at these little edges these
little edge features and build them back
together into your model and see which
position and orientation of your
airplane model best explains all this
edge data and so you can do that and
here's some more geometric things and so
this is where the field was for a long
time and then ok but now back to the
president ok so now we're going to deal
with real world images again my kids ax
is my son that's my daughter and their
friend so here let me talk about the
things that work and well this one I
maybe I should skip that vice when I
mentioned I can't come to Microsoft not
mention it one of the biggest advances
in computer vision was made by Paul
viola who's now at Microsoft doing
search and he threw out this paper which
i think is in pretty much every camera
now I mean I they haven't I haven't
heard from how the photographer how the
camera companies are doing their face
recognition but this is like the only
algorithm that could be fast enough to
do it so Paul came along and applied
nice machine learning
so called boosting which serve takes the
output of so-called weak learners
learners that classifiers that are just
a little bit above chance and and puts
them together and so coming up with a
classifier which just really lousy but
just barely works above chance yeah we
can do that you know we can make plenty
of those for example to find a face you
say well I'm just going to look for a
feature that's light here dark there
light there and that's that's a little
better than chance at finding where this
face is and so the boosting algorithm
are you all is it all a standard lingo
for you okay but so so it's a really
powerful machine learning algorithm that
it sort of corresponds to gradient
descent you know a particular cost
function and it lets in certain
structure how to combine these these
weak classifiers to build a so-called
strong classifier and so you can take in
the sort of image version of it you take
many different filters and see how well
they do at predicting whether or not
there's a face there and take the ones
to do a little better than chance and
combine them into a good classifier so a
number of the two ideas that Paul had
and his paper was to use these kind of
ugly looking filters but use lots of fun
and to calculate them very quickly using
a so called integral image where you
don't have to wait where you just some
every pixel value left to right and
bottom to top and the image once and
then you can calculate all these filter
responses very easily and you also
combined it with a cascade method is
just a paper of about side elegant ideas
which was really the most influential
computer vision paper past 10 or 20
years
yeah I mean many so many camp and not
all cameras many cameras have faith
detectors in them and surely this is the
algorithm using I just don't know of any
other they could be using so that's a
kind of a successful example of computer
vision self-applied a machine learning
stuff applied computer vision now here's
a way that is really an open problem for
computer scientists and that's this bag
of words representation so the second
most or maybe the most not enough tight
for a most influential paper was this
one by David Lough on so-called sift
features so here's the story originally
there were these so-called edge
detectors which look for little sharp
edges in the image but it's hard to
build up a you have to take a lot of
edges to really build up an informative
feature and so but on the other hand you
can't hardwire a whole lot of edge
positions because any slight change in
position or orientation is going to
change it from your template so you want
to have a kind of rich descriptor but at
the same time that allows a certain
amount of slop so here's what David
Lough designed and that's a little
basically a histogram of image gradients
so this is a patch of the image and here
are the little gradient values that
every from every little pair of pixels
in this patch and you sum them up and
make it a little histogram of how often
each gradient direction occurs in this
quadrant of this patch so so we have
four quadrants and here for gradient
histograms and and then we take all
these histograms and stack them up in a
feature vector and actually they used I
think four by four rather than two by
two shown here but you get then 128
dimensional number that is on the one
hand very rich in high-dimensional and
on the other hand allows for a lot of
slop you know you can change the precise
position of the line you look at the
same gradient histogram and so it's kind
of rich enough to be unique and yet
allows enough slop to allow for
viewpoint changes and lighting changes
that these things have absolutely taken
over a computer vision you know almost
every earth not every but maybe a third
of the papers just use this and
reference this paper
how many times from reference but it's
one of the big advances that it's okay
well there you go I'm going to of all
time of all papers all right okay fine
so it's like it's a big deal and they're
very useful so what can you do with them
well so let me show you so here's your
template you want to find this top if
you want to find that object now notice
by the way they're no longer you know
wrenches and things they're kind of more
realistic things and here's your image
you want to find them in so you look for
the little they're called sift scale and
variant feature transform you look for
your sift features and here's a little
box shown around each sip feature
location and then you look for all this
to feature than these guys and you match
them up so now you've got a computer
science problem you've got you want to
find the most likely position of this
thing that explains where you have the
most overlap between the sip features
here and the ones in the image and and
so you can find this very heavily
occluded frog behind this thing you can
find it because you've got enough of
these characteristic features that are
lighting up and you say well look it can
only be explained by the Frog you know
we've got you know 30 out of 300
features in common and they're all each
very distinctive so it's got to be this
frog so you can find these little
objects so there's one instance of the
train there's another instance of the
train and it finds them both and finds
the Frog because there's something I
haven't told you which is there's kind
of two steps to it there's finding the
location and scale and then there's
finding the descriptor I told you about
the descriptive part there's a
pre-processing step where you find the
proper scale and orientation in order to
then do this description stem so that's
how its scale invariant
yeah yeah that's how you matching yeah
yeah and you can and people have just
gone to town with these things right so
you can so they're hungry trait
dimensional you can also vector
quantized those things into little what
we're going to call words of visual
words so you might have maybe two or
three thousand different bins and that's
that's your vocabulary of what image
elements are and so now it becomes a
computer science problem you got an
image you find these features and each
one of them is an element in a histogram
possible so you could look at a training
set of images and do that so called
vector quantization on them to find
these cluster centers of these sift
descriptors and
no you dial that in how many you want to
get so it really depends on your
tolerance for noise but I'm just sort of
quoting the number that people report is
high enough to to really distinguish
objects and images so so now you look at
this image and you get this histogram
how many times you saw each of your two
or three thousand possible words and now
you go and compare it with your training
set of images of cars and say well do I
have a similar histogram or not a
similar to scram to that image of cars
and now it becomes a kind of computer
science problem of how much these two
histograms overlap you know how much
spatial variation do I want to allow you
know now it's back in the realm of
quantized discrete things and and now
it's a kind of comment towards yeah good
metric and magic find good matches
quickly now too that's a computer
science problem and so so there are a
lot of combinatorial matching problems
to be solved when doing object
recognition so here's one image of a
panda here's Anna it's a little hard to
see but there are these little feature
vectors there and you want to match them
up see does this one go with that one
and here there's shown in the feature
space and you can decide how tight you
want your bins in this feature space to
be you can also have bins in space
spatial position so there are a lot of
nice computer science problems here and
if you're interested in these sort of
combinatorial search problems this is a
great domain for you
depends on what he's going to retire
yeah yeah definitely yeah so and you
know there's and also there's this big
issue of the distinction between
so-called instance recognition and
category recognition if you just want to
find this one magazine cover well then
you can you know find the exact same
ones but if you want to cover all
categories of chairs then it's a it's a
big problem and and and it's a comment
or explosion problem the kind that
computer scientists handle so well so
anyway okay okay yes and then the I just
want to advertise says work because i
like it so much this is label transfer
this is another you know humph third
approach to doing object recognition
this is a I call it brain-dead vision
it's very cute and brained it in the
most positive sense so no is a pause
this so here's the here's the story you
have an input image you want to identify
all the objects in it you have this data
set that I haven't told you about yet
but you make it somehow which has lots
and lots of images all of them labeled
with the labelings that you want and
then you rely on the the impoverishment
of the visual world that there aren't
all that many images out there you know
if you have some new image it's going to
be like something in your data set and
you've got that thing in your data set
labeled so now all you have to do for
this brain-dead vision of human call it
is to find a nice correspondence between
this input image and this one from your
training set which has labeled on it and
so that's what so has done and he
developed this method called
sift flow which uses those features i
described and comes up with a sort of
meaningful correspondence between these
and then lets you drag those labels back
to your input image so here's here's how
it works you have an input image here's
a visualization of these sift features
color coded according to the first three
principal components and then here's
this warping let's see yeah the warping
of this image to the training set images
here's the corresponding warped sift
detector and then here's the Warped
annotations so now here's the game you
have all these warped candidate
annotations to describe this image you
want to combine them all sort of
adjudicating them come up with a single
best labeling well that's pretty easy by
this point because they're all
registered and you can have them vote
and here's the the output labeling from
this image and and all through the
system it really knows as it were
nothing about images it's just got this
nice label training set and knows how to
match up images to each other and it
grabs the label sucks up the labels from
the label training set and gives you a
new labeling and look how well it does
compared with ground truth and they they
have these remarkable numbers of like
seventy-five percent of the pixels are
actually active accurately labeled which
is just beautiful and and it's a kind of
exciting third approach to the object
recognition problem let's see seconds
ago so so I guess what's not shown yet
in this photo is the original data set
pictures or maybe they're sorry I go
back I think they're not in this yeah so
anyways I think I didn't grab them from
your slide but so these are preserved
pre warped so what you're not being
allowed to see in my display of it is
what these look like before the
registration to this guy but they were
you know three photos of cars and
traffic but looking significantly
different than this and then the the
beauty of this smashing is to be able to
take these in a way also haven't
described and align them properly to
these and then once you've got them
aligned he just grabbed the labels from
your training set and come up with
so I think this will have a lot of
influence it got this best paper prize
at the main computer vision conference
and so I expect it'll have a lot of
influence so I just went in the closing
part is going to show you so I last week
I went to this conference this workshop
in bath Canada was beautiful and it was
on computer vision in the internet it
sort of happened to have really you know
a very good approximation to the just
the top people in the field of computer
vision there so I went around and asked
them what can computer science tell
computer vision you know because I
wanted to hear I want to help help
preparing this talk so here are some of
the answers I God so let's see from this
trio in the modal response was nearest
neighbor search in high dimensions
that's really going to help computer
vision and you know it's going to help
with category recognition let's see oh
yeah nearest neighbor search but taking
into account our sorry should be our not
are our particular data or tell us what
questions we should be asking about our
data in order to do nearest neighbor
search well you know that would be
helpful to us and then then Rick
stilinski started just free associating
okay how do we how do we store all our
memories concepts objects in a very
large database you know it's so again
how do we manage this very large
database that we know is going to be
helpful to us a lot oh it's know a katie
tree is only useful to us in objects of
up to 20 dimensions but we have much
higher dimensional objects that we need
to work with a lot of people mentioned
parallelism how can we exploit it you
know help us with that we know that you
know lsh is supposed to work for doing
high dimensional nearly research but in
practice it doesn't work as well as we
wanted to so so this is a problem and
there are many references but here's one
reference okay shy of Eden had a nice
really crypto like computer science
helps oh yeah he's made this little
field he's calls blind vision so he
envisions a future where so I have an
image and you have an algorithm I don't
want to share my image with you
you you don't want to tell me your
algorithm but we want you to process my
image with your algorithm how can you do
it in a secure way so so for example
Alice has an input test pattern bob has
a classifier and Alice wants to have the
output would be the result of this
classifier on this image and Alice just
learns that result but nothing else in
Bob learns nothing about the test
pattern X so you have a secure set of
face security images you don't want to
share with anyone and somebody has a
face detector that they don't want to
tell you about and you apply them and
get the answer without anybody learning
anything they shouldn't know
I'm tired i went to take up Oh
huh
oh you mean that there's you're not
gonna be able to help us with this yeah
yeah okay so so the this blind vision is
really it's not really a subfield it's
more just one paper that this guy
published but you might find interesting
there might be like well so it's
interesting if we have distributed
processing on a given image so another
thing you might have a data so i may
have an image that I want to have some
hole filled in and you have a big data
set of images and you're just great and
it's filling in holes but you don't want
to show that to me and I don't want to
show you my image but we want to find
out whether there's a good match of this
image to your data set yeah okay yeah I
see ok
okay div arrahman on said he wants a way
to easily evaluate some function over a
power set of all segmentations
oftentimes if somehow we magically knew
what the right segmentation was for an
image ah everything would be easy you
know you just take that little segment
check it into your object recognizer and
be really quick to find everything out
if only we knew the right segmentation
well if somehow we could magically try
out all possible segmentations and
evaluate each one of them that would be
great so that's sort of a pipe dream I
don't know if that's possible or if you
can just prove for us it's not possible
so anyway that's another problem
evaluate some segmentation dependent
function over all possible segmentations
and that have lots of applications elder
chef rose a funny guy no he just said
the needle in the haystack problem is
what we only really need solved find the
signal or clusters when there's a lot of
noise find the pattern ignore the noise
so him and me and two others had these
crazy hats on he said find the picture
of from the pics from pictures of the
four of us with hats on determined that
it's a hat that we have in common David
Lough the guy who invented those
features what does he think needs to be
helped he thinks we need better features
so an artist can draw the end of an
elephant's trunk and you know
immediately what it is you know it just
absolutely captures the whole thing so
how can we capture the essence of these
visual objects with the local features
and then just one last thing if you
really want to publish it let me tell
you what the culture is for a long time
people published if only papers like if
only had a segmentation here's what I
would do and well we're no longer can
publish those papers you really have to
end to end systems now because who knows
if you can get that segmentation so so
it's really much more empirical now that
used to be so there's I in practice I
think a lot of overhead and coming up to
speed on the filters and representations
you need for images you need to evaluate
your validate your algorithm on a data
set or it can't get published there are
these competitive conferences have about
twenty or twenty-five percent acceptance
rates that's
the pain it's there's always a little
random coin toss whenever you submit
something on the other hand if you don't
publish their nobody knows about your
work so so there are these four
conferences you got to get it into one
of those or else no one learns about it
well yeah I mean that yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'll think about that I can't think
we want a fan but I mean for example
needs to be a lot of work done if we
just had a perfect signature from all
the edges here's what we could do but
then you just can't get that perfect
segmentation yeah but but you know
you've got this high-level processor in
there doing that manual thing yeah okay
okay okay right right but so so
especially so the story this slide is
that it's best to collaborate to
maximize your chances getting in and and
if you want to collaborate here's a lot
of people at MIT would be you know love
to work with bright theorists from
Microsoft I mean I can't guarantee
they'll all work with you but I can
guarantee they'll all take you seriously
if you're sending an email saying I'm
interested in doing this feeling is the
bureau my guess yeah
anyway here this is a list of you know
the list of the people doing vision and
competition photography working now my
team there's a lot of us and it's very
exciting place to be and what else oh
yeah so I just want some eye candy at
the very end so here's one this is um
this is not vision and this is this is a
this is work I've had really lot of
trouble getting published we finally got
it published but it's a lot of trouble
and because there's no good reason for
it that's why it's how you get published
we've made a system where you give us a
photograph and we start we combine it
with a large database of images and we
just start driving from your photograph
we in effect give your kind of joystick
can go forward go left you can write
your back starting from this photo and
we go and find photos that would fit
well with the left half of this picture
and blend it in well and make a little
video so so here this is the input
picture now let's start driving so
here's a video kind of you know turning
left and right from this input image and
all of this is made up from a large from
a large collection of flickr photographs
and yeah yeah no I just spotting us yeah
yes yes yeah yeah so I can show you
other ones of it well if that's okay um
so your original so we represented as
well again kind of similar idea
orientation great mystic owners of
orientation gradients a little of color
that's our representation we find that
to get this to work we had to we
couldn't just grab off flickr innocent
head bit grab them in filter into little
steams otherwise we jump crazily from
one thing to another so we developed a
theme classifier that would classify
flickr photographs as skyline or
landscapes or streets and others and
then we got this collection of several
thousand about 12 hundred thousand
within one theme and then we have
forward motion rotation camera pan and
then this is kind of the obvious thing
so you here's your input you want to
find out what would be there so you
translate and say well now i'm looking
for an image that has this over on this
side and then I care way it has over on
that side and you look for a good match
and then you kind of wiggle it around
then there are these graphics techniques
that we used to to define the best match
we we Whittle it around to till they
overlap the best and then we found the
best seam between the two images broke
their we use the so-called Prasad image
editing which finds the least where is
reconstruction that respects all the
gradients accept it it ignores all
gradients along this seam so it lets you
minimize the reconstruction artifacts so
there's the blended between this one and
the one we found there it looks pretty
seamless and it can do the same thing
rotation for rotation now we want to
find a picture that looks like this on
the left side and you know you can
simulate the whole thing and so here are
some you know composites that we made
which are just you know made up and
let's see oh yeah okay so here let me
show you some other ones so let's start
from a famous place and just go off to
the right see what's there so here's we
start from the Hollywood sign and let's
go off to the right
so right so in our quest to get this
published we you know kind of brainstorm
applications so one possible one is this
gives you a infinitely large photo
realistic virtual world so maybe four
games you know for second life or
whatever you could use this as a way oh
here's another one let's see so we go go
in we find elephants we back up from
their Indian phase ah well the feature
matching is going to be similar both
based on yeah it doesn't the right it's
honest about it and we're yeah and we
blend a little more heavily than they do
I think and now here I I know you've all
wondered what is off to the right of the
XP screensaver
so there's so that's it thank you very
much so you've all observed asking
questions a whole time we can I mean I'm
happy answer questions but it's also at
the end of the time so we can stop there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so anyway well
thanks a lot